all right so one of our favorite
refillable bits as we call them here is
I don't know it for a fact I just know
it's true and and this is you know this
it's so funny because this started
before Donald Trump this idea I was just
like you know there are things that I
can't prove I just know they're true and
now that's of course how we actually
operate in a government yeah but I like
to make a list every six months or so
for example I don't know it for a fact I
just know for a fact that Paul Manafort
will be played by Joe Pesci in the movie
I just know it's true
I don't know for a fact that if you
tried to pull out one of Donald Trump's
hairs the whole thing would unravel like
a Christmas sweater I I don't know for a
fact that all of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
sweaters are covered in cat hair I just
I don't know for a fact that Johnny Depp
calls friends in the middle of the night
and says am i turning into Nicolas Cage
enough for fact it even if I didn't know
Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross's name I
would guess it was Wilbur Ross I don't
know for a fact that when people talk
about seeing other people they're
already banging someone else that would
hurt I don't know for a fact that
vibrators think dildos are lazy
[Laughter]
I don't know for a fact that Colin
Kaepernick's sometimes takes a knee just
so the people behind him can see that
your therapist is infinitely more
disturbed than you'll ever be